si la ville de cilaos est connu pour son
magnifique paysage ces randonnées à pied
ou à vtt son vin ou encore ses ventes y
il y un trésor qui fait aussi la fierté
des habitants du cirque de lille et de
la réunion générale sa broderie la
fonderie d'esi la hausse a été créée par
angèle mac auliffe et c'est une
réunionnaise pas deux mais réunionnais
et des pères breton donc elle est née à
hell bourg à salazie donc son père était
médecin des thermes et il est venu
habiter à cilaos donc avec tes hanches
elle et sa famille l'histoire de la
broderie de cilaos commence donc à la
fin du 19e siècle
contrairement aux idées souvent
véhiculés ce ne sont pas les soeurs qui
ont emmené l'activité dans ce village
des hauts mais bien une jeune fille
angèle mac auliffe soeur du célèbre
médecin
victor mac auliffe et il crée à ce qu'on
appelle à cilaos la technique du jour
anciens et transmis son savoir faire à
des jeunes filles qu'elles accueillaient
dans un petit pavillon derrière la
maison de son père ce n'est que plus
tard
en 1953 une religieuse soeur anastasia
pris sa relève
créé en 1953 c'est une religieuse donc
c'était s'il a osé ennemi si elle a
ouvert fin c'est elle qui a créé louvois
et donc elles prenaient tous les
commandes des dons qu'elle a pris à des
jeux de johnny fiducie la hausse et elle
prenait tous les commandes mais c'est
elle qui partager le travail dans la
maison de la broderie fraîchement rénové
ses dalida qui accueille le public et
quand elle ne répond pas au téléphone ou
qu'elle n'est pas dans la paperasse elle
brode al étage du petit bâtiment
deux autres brodeuses et suzanne maillot
a bien connu sera la stagiaire c'est
elle qui lui a appris son métier et nous
explique la particularité du jour de
cilaos larrory blanche
on pour le dessin et en déca sur le
tissu et on travaille sur le tissu mais
les jo de cilaos
on fait d'abord un tracé pour pouvoir
est vide et les carrés parce que le jeu
de cilaos et ça il faut éviter et
travailler dans le vide et c'est là
qu'en remettant des fils c'est là qu'on
peut travailler les motifs sur les fils
qu'on a tendu et la borie blanche et
travailler directement sur le tissu avec
plus de 50 ans de broderie susan est une
pièce maîtresse dans la transmission de
ce savoir faire local lé maître d'art
plusieurs fois décoré notamment par
l'ancien président de la république
française françois mitterrand quartier
48 ans de métier mais avec tous les
trois ans d'apprentissage mais savait
depuis 50 ans j'ai eu la médaille
d'argent au concours des meilleurs
ouvriers de france
j'ai eu la médaille d'or en 94 des co
réalisé par monsieur mitterrand et puis
en 95 bah j'ai eu le titre de maître
d'art aujourd'hui de moins en moins de
brodeuses vivent de leur métier
cela s'explique par le prix des ouvrages
largement justifiée mais aussi par le
manque de clients
mais ce que susan regrette par dessus
tout c'est le manque d'intérêt porté par
la jeunesse pour son activité et la
crainte de voir ce patrimoine s'envoler
avant je trouve que ça on n'y avait plus
de touristes il y avait plus ami a quand
même
donc il faut essayer de faire il ya des
plus de touristes ce que je moi je
demande que notre broderie soit reconnue
parce que c'est pas reconnu notre gros
dryats ya la beauté d'alençon s'est
reconnue par l'unesco
si notre brownies et broderies et
reconnu je suis sûr qu'on aura d'autres
personnes qui vont venir et surtout
attirer les jeunes
un pas qu'elle puisse reprendre le
relais appelé parce que ce serait
dommage de perdre et ça si la hausse